there's this great cliche which is this
when you go to watch a film that has
been adapted from a novel the film is
never ever as good as the book you know
it generally kind of feels like it's
true right like Hitchhiker's Guide to
the galaxy amazing book terrible film
Northern Lights amazing book terrible
film Harry Potter and the Deathly
Hallows Part 1 I mean that was just
everyone should be embarrassed about
that really the book was amazing
obviously films not quite so good and I
started thinking maybe maybe Hollywood
takes good books and just makes them
into fire fields maybe but good book
equals a bad film especially when you
think about actually there are some
books that aren't quite so good that do
make good films like Bridget Jones's
Diary all right book but actually pretty
good film the Martian as well I think
you know the film probably was a bit
better than the book but it was an OK
book an OK book amazing film so maybe
there is this thing that Hollywood's
ruins good books but also maybe it just
appears that way
because of a statistical fallacy called
books and paradox go with me on this for
a second let's imagine that there is no
connection whatsoever of all of the
possible stories in the world if you
plotted them on this as to how good a
film they make and how good a book they
make actually there's no connection
whatsoever that you just got this this
kind of mishmash of dots right like this
now the slight problem here when you're
looking at the data or you're thinking
about films that that sort of answer
this question is that you are only
considering a very small subsection of
all of the possible stories right so
you're only thinking about films that
were good so we're kind of up here so
this is where all the good films are or
you're only thinking about good books
right so books they're kind of down here
so generally speaking the only ones that
are sort of in your consciousness are
going to be above this line here all of
these dots here so either very good
films or very good books why Hanna why
aren't we considering what's below that
well because either a book
is so bad that it never gets made into a
film for a film that's been made from a
book is so bad that you never heard of
it you know like Count of Monte Cristo
and I've seen that film no it was
terrible absolutely atrocious so it just
isn't really in your consciousness
because the film is kind of so is so bad
we don't know about bad books we don't
know about all they don't even get made
into a film so we don't know that
exactly right exactly right but the end
result is that you're only ever
considering a very small subsection of
this on this you've got films like maybe
Harry Potter is down here Harry Potter
Deathly Hallows you got maybe the
Martian is go over here Godfather that
kind of thing but you're not considering
any of this stuff so if you just redraw
this graph with all the data that you
can see all the data that's sort of
available to you so bearing in mind all
of these stories here aren't really in
your consciousness it almost looks like
there's this negative correlation if you
were to draw a trend line through this
data it looks as though Hollywood really
is ruining books because it takes the
best books and makes them into bad films
if these are the stories that you think
about all the books that are really good
- the ones that are over here if you
kind of think about the average goodness
of film of all of the books that are
really good it's kind of going to be
around about here it's like a mediocre
film whereas if you're over here these
kind of mediocre books and you look at
the average goodness of the film that
they make actually they make pretty good
films right so it almost looks as though
the goodness of the book is negatively
related to the goodness of the film as
though if your Hollywood exec you want
to try and find books down here not very
good books basically to make those ones
into films because statistically they'll
make you're better films sort of doesn't
make any sense and it's because you're
only considering a really small
subsection of the population so this
here is Burton's paradox it was
discovered by a guy called Joseph
Bergson after he was working in
hospitals and trying to collect data on
the different diseases that people had
and found these negative correlations
between things that you wouldn't you
know you wouldn't necessarily expect so
let's say that you had diabetes
and severe ingrown toenails for instance
he went into hospital and there's kind
of negative correlation right so here
are your toenails and here are your
diabetes so this is kind of like how
extreme your cases are so more extreme
cases aren't gonna be out here so there
were some people who had bad cases of
both but it looked as though if you had
diabetes you were less likely to have
bad toenails people with most diabetes
the worst diabetes tended to have the
best toenails and likewise people with
the worst toenails down here tended to
have you know alright diabetes but it's
this negative correlation but actually
isn't really there because of course in
the whole population actually there are
all those people down here you have kind
of not very bad toenails or not very bad
diabetes but they're just not the ones
who are in hospital so if you're only
considering the people who are in
hospital who are there because they have
only the bad toenails or bad diabetes
you end up getting this sort of spurious
correlation between things that isn't
really there my favorite example of this
is in Jordan and the Berg's book how not
to be wrong and he talks about there's
that sort of old adage that very
beautiful people are assholes and that's
another example of Burke's as paradox
but you kind of take this one step
further because on that example here so
this is sort of good-looking so the
prettiest people going to be over here
and this here is niceness
so the nicest people are gonna be up
here and you've got sort of again you've
got all of this data like this in the
real population actually there's no
connection between them you get nice
people all across the spectrum and you
get good-looking people all across the
spectrum of niceness the thing is is
that if you are dating people the people
that you're considering there's sort of
a level of good-looking this that you
you generally don't go below and there's
a level of niceness that you generally
don't go below so even though this is
the whole population when you're talking
about the people that you would date
there is this line here you're only
really considering the people to this
side of this line so it looks like
there's a negative
between niceness and good-looking girls
if you're talking about very very
good-looking people the range that they
have in terms of niceness is kind of the
full spectrum but the average niceness
that they have is like somewhere in the
middle as in not very nice but meanwhile
the ugliest people that you would
consider going out with are actually
only the people at the very top of this
line - they're only the very nicest
people so it looks like there's this
downward trend right so sort of the
average here is up here and the average
down here is kind of somewhere about
there so it looks like there's this
downward trend and with this example in
particular if you also add to this that
the very sort of most attractive people
of all are gonna be up here in this
other triangle up here so the very
nicest and most good-looking people are
actually gonna be in this triangle over
here and probably they're not gonna want
to go out with you so these people are
off-limits to you anyway all you're left
with is this very very narrow channel of
people who you'd be willing today and
who'd be willing to date you and that is
definitely a negative correlation or at
least it looks like one so just to prove
that there isn't this negative
correlation the sort of secret negative
correlation that the Hollywood ruining
good books
I spoke to journalist called Walter
Hickey who has done some announce it
this way he has downloaded the data for
all of the films that he could find
which were both made into a film and
were released as a novel so he got the
Metacritic score which kind of like a
posh her version of Rotten Tomatoes
essentially and he also got the
Goodreads score which is again similar
sort of thing a user-generated score so
you've got the goodness of the book
along the bottom and the goodness of the
film along the top and when you look at
it first
it looks very heavily skewed which isn't
necessarily fair because scores on
Goodreads tend to be quite good tend to
be quite high people are quite positive
about things the scores they arranged
between noir and 5 whereas on Metacritic
they is a percentage between no.1 and
100 and the thing is is that if you do
finish a book and then take the time to
review it you're probably going to have
enjoyed the book a little bit right if
it's a really rubbish book you just
would put it down before you got to that
stage so this graph here doesn't totally
represent the data very well instead
what you can do is you can use something
called a z-score which is a little
statistical trick that gives you a score
of how good something is compared to all
of the other data and it kind of
normalizes everything for you because
you're a slightly more accurate picture
of what's going on so this here and this
is the real data here you've got your
goodness of your book along the bottom
and the goodness of your film along the
top and actually you can see that if
anything I mean there's almost like a
positive correlation right you've got
lots of films over here that make both
good books and good films you've got
some that make I think this one is up in
the air I've never seen that film view
telling whether it's very good but
apparently critics loved it Godfather I
think is one of these the date is
generally actually quite spread out you
certainly haven't got this this negative
trend the only thing that you don't see
here there's that sort of these these
gaps over here and that is because of
course very bad books never get made
into films whereas with the good looking
example you wouldn't date people who you
didn't consider either nice or good
looking you know people don't read bad
books but they do watch terrible films
so if the book was better than the movie
then you would want your data to be all
down on this side right so if you had a
diagonal line anything on that side of
the line would be the movies better than
the book and anything on that side of
line would be the book is better than
the movie
and actually he says the line there I
mean it's maybe a bit skews that often
the book is better thing is at the very
beginning when we're thinking about that
sort of almost negative correlation
people just don't remember all of these
films or all of these books that I mean
the ones in this I've gone through the
days I didn't I've never even heard of
most of them so when it comes to famous
films and famous books that's when you
get more of the book is better than the
film
yeah I think so I think so or very least
when you get famous books and famous
films it's like a Hollywood ruined the
good book
then they didn't there's a lot of bad
books on there yeah not yours they know
you know the debate about books versus
movies is irrelevant to me because I
think the perfect compromise is an
audiobook and Hannah who you just
watched she's got a brand new book out
she's recorded it as an audio book and I
went along as she recorded some of it
the book is called hello world how to be
human in the age of the Machine people
are less tolerant of their own even if
their own mistakes bigger
Hannah's books already getting great
reviews it's been nominated for a really
amazing prize as well and I'll tell you
what it really comes to life when you
hear it read by the author herself
Hannah's got such a great voice and
gives it so much personality the
algorithms that silently follow us
around the internet the ones that are
harvesting our personal information the
best place of course to get your
audiobooks is audible and they are the
supporter of today's episode if you go
to audible.com slash numberphile or text
the word numberphile to 500 500 you can
start there 30-day trial with that you
can download a free book you can
download any book but of course I'm
gonna recommend hello world Hannah's new
one definitely worth getting well the
thing is actually you don't really read
your own book I mean the first time I
read mine was when I was taking the
audio book because I mean you you're
sort of like doing little bits here and
there and then you know you didn't never
have a chance that sort of sit down and
read it all in one go
so that was quite nice quite reassuring
to know that actually as a book it does
work these disparate chunks of text that
emerge together audiobooks are great
when you're lying in bed going on a long
road trip walking the dog I love
listening to them and I think you're
gonna really enjoy a hello world
audible.com slash numberphile for the
trial for the free book which can be
hello world if you want it to be or text
numberphile to 500 500 our thanks to
them for supporting this episode